hi there steve kaufman here
i just came back from my uh 10-day trip
to france uh i was there selling
cedar shakes and shingles
these are consumed in france primarily
in the mountains in the savoia area
and so i was
in makko the first night then we were up
in bonnville and ansi in that area in
the savoia and we ended up down in
valance because we have a customer in
that area and i had a wonderful meal and
of course i was speaking french every
day and having a great time really
enjoying myself
and i didn't have time to study any
korean of course
one interesting thing that happened to
me
i was in paris and there was a meetup of
the polyglot group
uh they advertised themselves on the
internet polyglot.com i think
uh vance who is the founder or at least
the organizer he was there i had a i
have communicated with him but this is
my first chance to meet with him
and there are
up to a hundred people who once or twice
a week gather
to speak different languages uh when i
was last in paris i also happened to be
there
at a time when they had one of their
meetings and at that time
the discussion while we had different
tables with flags on the tables and so
you could float from a
chinese table to a spanish table to a
german table and so forth english table
this time most of the people seem to be
interested in learning english
uh varian you know obviously very
enthusiastic people most of them were
french but there were also people there
from
japan
from
jordan from
spain
trying to remember here
china
u.s
different people exchanging languages
but very heavily oriented towards
english
and
people who very much wanted to improve
their english very um
motivated people
um but then i came home and of course i
bought some books in french and i'm
reading french i bought a book on
a biography of francois pomier who was
the king in the in the 1500s very much
involved with introducing the
renaissance to france
um
i read a few other books in french
one on the economy of happiness which
was kind of interesting
um
but then you know i i have this korean
lurking in the background that i want to
get back to
but then i'll uh have to write something
in russian on our forum at link and i
struggle and to use it and i refer to
google translate to help me
get going on this thing and and so i
really would like to spend more time on
my russian not to mention my check
but even at this meet up speaking in
german or spanish i realize that there
are gaps in my knowledge of these
languages
so the issue always is you know how much
you know i even and i was in a bookstore
in london and
because i visited in london my son and
his family lived there and i always
liked going to the bookstores there and
i was toying with getting
looking at what they're doing at any
rate in arabic and of course the first
obstacle in arabic is the writing system
which i would have to get a handle on i
think before i started studying arabic
at linc
but then i said geez if i take on arabic
i haven't even gotten as far as i want
to get in korean
i still want to improve my russian and
czech not to mention all my other
languages with every language you take
on
it's more and more difficult
to take any of your other languages up
to a higher level which i would also
like to do there's only only so many
hours of the day and i typically only
have an hour or so because i also like
to read on different subjects and so
forth so the question is you know how
much how much do you want to be a
perfectionist now obviously someone who
needs say english for their work
they can't afford to be a dilettante i'm
more of a dilettante
and so i've kind of decided i'm not
going to allow myself to be
to feel pressure
uh i'll speak those languages as well as
i speak them period and there will
always be people who will criticize me
and say that my whatever language is no
good and they do that on youtube
regularly so that's fine but as i often
say you know language is for ourselves
so
i derive tremendous enjoyment from all
the languages that i speak
uh from being able to understand
from being able to communicate albeit
with mistakes so i'm happy i i achieve
you know uh what i want to achieve i get
back what i put in
um
so i guess and i think that's good
enough so for those of us who study more
than one language
uh or who are doing it as a hobby we
shouldn't feel pressure i think we
shouldn't feel this pressure to be
perfect nail down the grammar make sure
we understand everything and i often get
emails from people or comments here at
youtube i've been studying such and such
a language for so long and i still can't
understand the movies or i still make
mistakes or have trouble expressing
myself and i think we shouldn't
allow ourselves to be sort of hounded by
by this inability to be as good as we
would like to be that's always going to
be there you always have this feeling as
i have that i in all my languages that i
could be better and if i had the time
then i would devote myself to trying to
get better i mean japanese i'd like to
get reading japanese literature and
expand my vocabulary in that direction
and
there's no end you know i've got 12
languages that i claim i speak and
korean would be the 13th and in every
one of them i could improve if i had
more time to spend on listening and
reading and
noticing and gathering phrases and so
forth
however what do you do so as long as
you're just a dilettante like me you're
doing it for fun you can quite
comfortably say i don't care what people
say i'm happy
the languages work for me for what i
want to do with them and i don't allow
myself to get frustrated by
the obvious shortcomings in my
ability to use these languages but what
about if you need it for work there's no
question that if you are
professional let's say if you're an
immigrant to canada
you're an accountant you're an engineer
you have to speak english and write
english very well and i know many
non-native speakers who write
better than the average canadian in
english
and who speak although with an accent
but who express themselves better more
eloquently than the average native
speaking english-speaking canadian so
that can be achieved so for those people
what do they need to do well obviously
they need to concentrate and if i
were to move to a country let's say you
know czech republic russia spain
anywhere where i had to do business in
that language
that was the main language of business
that i was sending out letters or emails
then i would totally focus on that
language and i would
read a lot in that language i would you
know obviously save words and phrases
review these words and phrases i would
probably get a teacher to
correct my writing again not because i'm
going to immediately improve after the
correction but because it's it's just
helps me to to focus in on areas of
weakness and and look for those things
when i'm reading and speaking and and
so i and i believe that if i were if i
had the luxury of focusing on spanish or
chinese or czech that i could take it up
to a very very high level so i
deliberately
choose
not to do that because i'm interested in
exploring other languages
but there's a limit you know maybe
arabic and turkish
but then i may just you know stop there
or maybe just kind of explore some of
the others much the way moses does moses
mccormick he explores a variety of
languages it's all good it's all a
matter of what we want to do
you know it's a matter of whether you
want to be an expert in a small number
or you want to travel and see and
experience a variety of languages so
those are all valid
goals
so i guess my conclusion is that
how perfect we need to be depends on
your goals if you are working in a
language where you need the language
professionally you have to devote
yourself to becoming as good as you can
be
you have to become very attentive you
have to
see
and notice
uh excellent use of the language in
others when you're reading and listening
and you have to therefore see and notice
when you yourself are not using the
language as effectively as you could and
this is not a matter of accent i don't
think accent really matters i've said it
before i deal with people here in canada
my father as i mentioned who
handled himself very well here in
english always had a strong accent
the accent i don't think is a big issue
but you can
train yourself to notice what is good
usage effective efficient use of the
language by the natives and you can get
very close to imitating that yourself if
you focus on that language but if your
desire is to know a number of languages
because you like to travel you like to
read in different languages watch movies
in different languages
be able to communicate with people that
you come across in your travels then
don't get upset because you don't
achieve perfection in three or four
different languages
just
again as i always say pat yourself on
the back for what you are able to do
derive enjoyment from it enjoy it
and don't
allow yourself
to be feel frustrated
and and i say that and yet and yet i
must admit that at times it bothers me
that i'm not better in some of the
languages
that i claim to speak but i just don't
have time
to achieve a higher level in some of
those if i also want to have fine time
to learn new languages not to mention
reading leading the rest of my life so
how perfect do we need to be it's
entirely up to us it depends on what our
goals are but if we need to be very good
in the language we can do it as long as
we don't have unrealistic expectations
when it comes to accents
and we accept the fact that we will make
the odd mistake thanks for listening bye
for now